Now, I don't know about you, but every time I come across the halting problem,
I cannot buy the mathematical arguments, but I still feel some would cheat it.
It's important I think to realize what is being implied by undecidability and what is not being implied.
Informally, all that the undecidability of the halting problem says
is that you cannot analyze every aspect of computation using computation.
Let's say this program here is supposed to solve the halting problem.
This would be the program halt here.
The difficulty lies in the fact that all this required not only to be able to say what one given program
program two does, and of course, we'll assume there's also an input,
but basically, it's supposed to be able to say this for an infinite number of programs.
Now, the following is by no means a scientific explanation,
but I think it's a good way to think about it.
If we have the requirement that halt must be able to look at every other problem here
then halt will also be part of this list.
So somewhere in that stack of programs, you will have halt.
Now, if you say halt must be more complex, and again, this is not a scientific explanation
must be more complex that any program it's looking at,
well, then halt must be more complex than halt itself,
which of course is to an infinite cycle of complexity.
So here, we cannot have this spiral of infinity, which of course cannot be so there's the error right there,
and again, this is just an intuition a way which I like to think about it.
You may find other ways more convenient.
What I find is with undecidability and especially the halting problem
there is a lot of misunderstandings and pitfalls.
And actually, I would now like to go with you through one of the most common pitfalls
regarding the halting problem and its undecidability.